I'm just here to like you know saying
man up to what I did we don't saying
like don't audio my bad language I'm
gonna man up to that I'm saying like I
don't want nobody talking to my little
sister my daughter that I have now you
know I'm saying my mom like that you
know I'm saying it's very disrespectful
and I mean my mom got on to me like she
like dumped me in the air like come on
Mary come on come on grow up grow up out
of that so I never again like I said I'm
going as a human being as a person and
I'm never again that's Chiefs receive
retiree kill at training camp meeting
with reporters not all that long ago it
looked like he was gonna miss some time
this year the NFL decided not to
discipline him in any way and he was
specifically referring in that little
clip that we played to the comment that
he made to his former fiancee Krystal
espen all you need to be terrified of me
to be when they were talking about
whether or not his three-year-old son
either respects Tyreke Hill or is
terrified of him he didn't know he was
being recorded it was a statement that
shocked me when I heard and I thought
for sure Chris he would be suspended for
that statement alone the NFL took no
action against him he's he's saying all
the right things now when he knows his
voice is being recorded let's see if he
does all the right things as we move
forward yeah that's the million dollar
question he I mean to win me back he's
certainly gonna have to do the right
things going forward for you know
consistently for a long period of time I
mean you know again like we said in the
first hour I love watching Tyreke he'll
play
I mean he's as fast as any guy we've
ever seen in the history of NFL I mean
he's Darrell Green Deion Sanders type
speed he's so explosive
he's probably the number one weapon in
football at the wide receiver position
but yeah as a human being he's not my
favorite right now and he's got to kind
of earn my trust back seems like he's
going in the right direction I hope he
matures listen I'm very understanding
that football players
what makes guys like Tyree kill and
other superstars in the NFL good at
times is because they are emotional they
have tempers it's what allows them to
play out there on the field in front of
70,000 people and this craziness and
this crazy sport but at the same time
it's got to be shut off when you're off
the field then you got to be a grown man
and act like a
or a father and those are the things
that I read kill certainly needs to
improve on and Kris Tyreke hill spent
some time yesterday talking about growth
that he doesn't want to change as much
as he wants to grow and he he shared a
story that his mother had imparted him
about basically being a tree where a
tree grows a tree adds layers a tree
grows over time and that's what he's
trying to do and I and I'm fine with
that as well it sounded very good he
just has to be committed to it there was
one exchange that happened just he was
only available to media for eight
minutes
and and for me you know I felt like for
a guy who's trying to turn the page on
an ugly chapter in his life a chapter
that he took some responsibility for as
it relates to that comment that we all
heard that made us think he was
definitely being suspended he was asked
a question by a reporter who has
reported some negative things about
Tyreke Keough had has had some opinions
about tyree killed he probably doesn't
agree with and it looks like he still
holds a little bit of a grudge and he
left that sneak out a little bit on
Sunday here's the exchange that he had
with Brooke Pryor of the Kansas City
Star what do you mean what's your name
there's been great me and coach Reed
like you said when you talk doing the
whole offseason I mean I really ain't
talked to nobody but I mean but my
teammates so it's been great now look
I'm gonna get her a little bit of credit
because he gathered himself I think he
was thinking about saying so I know you
right yeah he was certainly went through
his mind
something went through his mind I'm with
you my guy I hear he's tiny and he
stopped himself right but but there's
there's no reason to ask her name
there's no reason to smirk when you hear
the name yeah and and and you know it's
okay for him to hold a grudge inside
internally when you're in that this is
your reintroduction to the world they
had it live on NFL Network this is your
eight-minute window where people are
gonna watch you and come to conclusions
about whether or not they think you're a
good guy or a bad guy yeah and you throw
in that little lapse and it's gonna make
people say okay he's just saying what he
needs to say and deep down he still
that same guy who will say something
horrible to somebody close to him if
that person says something to him that
he doesn't like yeah he's got to find a
way to wipe all those emotions away and
not get personal with this whole thing
and again go back to himself you need to
grow right I mean you're it is you at
the heart of this situation that is
responsible for all this it's your
actions it's your words it's the things
you've done
that are aired they're making this woman
Brooke who I don't know her last name I
missed it there but either way she has
every right to ask those questions again
you're a superstar in the NFL that's
done some really shady questionable
things don't be mad at a member of the
media for doing something they're paid
to do and it wasn't like it was like bad
or you know just illegitimate or bad
reporting or whatever it may be it was
very much justified and yes you're right
it's gonna be better for Tyree kill to
just get off that stuff don't get over
it they reported it I'm saying bad
things about you Mike Florio said bad
things about you you know why cuz you
did bad things but just get it over and
move on and like his mom said grow as a
person
he mentioned himself he has a bad
history and he does and we heard what he
said and see that's I can't reconcile
taking responsibility for the horrible
thing you said and then being mad at
people who reacted to it in a way that
confirms yes it was a horrible thing
that you said so the grudge and acting
out on the grudge doesn't mesh with this
supposed apology and commitment to
growth and change so he's got some work
to do to win me over and you over and a
lot of other people over we'll see if he
can do that work
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports